[Music]
if you're destined to become a chef the
food centric city of New Orleans ain't a
bad place to grow up John currence was
born and raised there by a family that
loved to cook and loved to travel while
living in the UK they often took trips
around Europe sampling its many cuisines
after cooking jobs around the South
current settled in Oxford Mississippi in
1992 and opened city grocery and want
him the 1992 James Beard Award for Best
Chef in the South welcome and thank you
so much for this lovely meal thank you
thank you for having me
so tell us you call you call breakfast
the Forgotten meal well more than
neglected meal I think you know I've
forgotten here on this table well no and
it's never really forgotten but but
chefs just kind of neglected we sort of
shuffled it off to to Cracker Barrel and
and Waffle House I felt like it was
really a visit to Andrew Carmellini
'he's Locanda Verde that made me realize
about 15 years ago is like wow why why
aren't we really applying more thought
to this meal it just seems like a
freebie and the the segment's wide open
we got on the table good well we start
with this is actually sort of oddly
chronological this coffee cake is a
banana the conical cake that was meant
to mimic one from a bakery right across
the street from our house at about once
every two weeks my mom would give my
brother and I a couple of bucks to go
get something to eat and that coffee
cake was was my favorite the buttermilk
biscuits and tomato gravy were just a
staple at my my grandmother's table this
sort of pile of breakfast meats that we
have here that breakfast sausage is
actually my grandfather's recipe he was
the he was the sausage maker in their
community when they had hog slaughter
and so that was the sausage that he made
and served out of his little country
store the Low Country skillet which is
our smoked sausage and andouille and
shrimp is you know is just one of one of
those one pan dishes that folks just
love because I think you know no matter
what anybody says they love to mix their
food up and just sort of shovel it in as
quickly as possible
the shakshuka down in the the pan down
the table is came from a trip to Israel
that took with Michael Solomonov which
is one of the greatest gifts of
ever been given in my life this is also
delicious for you I mean when did you
really become interested in food I read
a quote from you said it was literally
out of the birth canal you were
interested well I mean it's it's New
Orleans and so you're either interested
or you're exiled you know it was such a
you know huge part of my life whether it
was at hunting and fishing camp whether
it was my my mother who traveled
internationally with my father on
business who was fascinated with the
kitchen and would bring the foods home
of the places that she had been whether
it was you know India or Cairo or
Western Europe and recreate these things
but I mean food was just it was all over
great life your first memory of food was
the smell of it was it your
grandmother's chocolate chip cookies my
great grandmother your great-grandmother
yeah that my daughter is actually named
for it wasn't intentional but it's a
beautiful name her name is Mamie and so
that that's that's how we arrived there
but yeah that was my very first food
memory I heard that you are said to hire
in the South tell us about your latest
book and how that adds to your empire
Empire is kind of terrifying considering
the current state of affairs breakfast
you're in Alabama you're thinking about
South Carolina you're in Mississippi in
Florida in Florida yeah and Charleston
we're building in Charleston has been a
long process but really really excited
about that store coming along and and
now actually going back and doing a
restaurant that I've wanted to do for
years with our chef from snack bar
vishesh Bhatt who is one of my dearest
friends in the world
is from Gujarat and so we're gonna we're
going to put together sort of a southern
influenced Indian Street food restaurant
and so you guys and you all are the
first to know about that well I'm gonna
have you sign our dish and as I do ask
you if you could have this meal with
anyone past or present who would it be
well that's an easy answer for me right
now I just lost my mother who was one of
the greatest influences in my entire
life and says to to have one more meal
with her would be the the greatest
opportunity in the world I love nothing
more than cooking breakfast with my
daughter and
why sort of dragging out and having
coffee and so those are you know those
are my my greatest joys in life so I
mean I think the three most important
women in my life would be at breakfast
no question about it
that's a phenomenal meal as well chef
John currence thank you thank you guys
and for more on chef currents and the
dish you can head to our website at CBS
this morning calm